[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques pour
notre pays et sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation récemment un certain nom
du journaliste parlementaire se sont
émus de la libération prochaine de
djihadistes
à londres le 2 février un membre du
groupe etat islamique libéré de prison
en janvier après avoir accompli la
moitié de sa peine attaqué au couteau
trois personnes ans le 30 novembre 2019
y'a pas longtemps avaient déjà eu lieu à
londres le même type d'attac
il est donc légitime de se poser la
question flavien moreau le premier
jihadiste condamné à son retour de syrie
a été libéré fin janvier la ministre de
la justice mme belloubet annonce la
sortie en 2020 de 43 jihadistes et d'une
soixantaine en 2021
tandis que le député guillaume larrivé
précise qu'ils seront 140 avant fin 2022
sur les 531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie de
ces individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
le chercheur hugo miche roncq est un
spécialiste de la radicalisation il a
fait beaucoup de travaux là dessus aussi
bien chez nous quand à l'étranger et
dans les prisons en particulier pense
qu'on pourra répondre à ce défi si nous
sommes capables de sortir des postures
idéologiques et des erreurs
d'interprétation
pour comprendre où nous en sommes il
faut revenir au début de l'histoire en
france une quinzaine de zones qui ne
sont pas forcément marginalise
économiquement ou situés en banlieue ont
été sélectionnés dans les années 90 par
des militants djihadistes et cette
grosse dizaines de salafistes qui se
sont placés dans le sillage des frères
musulmans d'établi guy est également ne
l'oublions pas des turcs des musulmans
turcs se sont implantées à travers de
petites structures qui ont servi de base
de développement
certains d'entre eux ont été faire la
guerre en bosnie avec les katibas à la
piste financé par le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite pour faire le jihad contre les
serbes chrétiens mais en dehors de
quelques dérives criminelles qui ont
suivi cette expérience des balkans ils
en ont tiré expérience et prestige dans
leur environnement
mais pendant ce temps là les autres ont
continué à mailler les zones
sélectionnées en faisant du prosélytisme
et en promouvant la charia et en
s'étendant il faut bien dire que le
salafisme à x 200 300 à peu près le
nombre de ses pratiquants
entre l'époque de la bosnie est celle du
démarrage de la syrie les jihadistes
français ont commencé à s'intéresser à
la syrie à partir de 2012
quand elle est devenue terre de jihad
rappelons qu'il s'agissait
conformément à la doctrine salafiste de
construire un état religieux
copié sur celui des premiers califes
ayant succédé à mahomet et n'oublions
pas car cela explique beaucoup de choses
que cette idée était inacceptable pour
les musulmans chiites et reste
inacceptable pour les musulmans chez
puisque cette époque leur rappelle
l'assassinât d'ali le gendre de mahomet
qui aurait dû lui succéder et qui a été
éliminé dans la compétition de sa
succession
la deuxième vague vers la syrie était
essentiellement composé de responsables
de cette mouvance existant en france et
qui était en liaison avec les pionniers
déjà parties et avec les organisations
terroristes en place cette vague est
arrivée au moment de la guerre
fratricide c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire entre al nostra qui était affilié à
al qaïda et que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans la région d'idlib sous
le nom de hayat tard et al cham et des
shows l'état islamique qui voulait
s'imposer à tout prix 90% des arrivants
français ont choisi des ch pour qu'ils
ont combattu avec un niveau de perte
très élevé pour beaucoup du fait de ces
combats terribles extrêmement dur le
rêve est devenu cauchemar
et nombreux sont ceux qui sont revus
depuis
il bénéficie du prestige des anciens
combattants auprès de la communauté
musulmane salafistes tabligh ou frères
musulmans qui les entoure après ces deux
premières vagues y en a une troisième
s'est déroulée principalement entre 2014
et 2016 et celle là a vu des milliers de
jeunes hommes et de femmes français
musulmans ou fraîchement convertis
originaires des quartiers les plus
défavorisés ou issus de la classe
moyenne
partir pour le jihad
la première erreur de notes
administrations et les politiques
français en général a été de croire que
les terroristes comme mohamed merah en
2012 étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
salafistes
la deuxième a été de penser que les gens
partent en syrie allait pour se faire
tuer pour rejoindre le paradis d'allah
alors que leur but est là tous les
toutes les études le montrent était de
fonder un véritable état islamique
appliquant les règles et la loi
islamique
la troisième erreur a été de se
contenter d'interprétation très rapide
sans chercher vraiment à comprendre à
égoutter les rares spécialistes qui
avait compris comme par exemple gilles
kepel ou à la jouer comme l'a rappelé
amine boutaghane l'ancien patron de
l'ugt klatch jusqu'au début de cette
année à la fin des années 90 et au début
des années 2000 les dérives urbaines ont
commencé à cohabiter avec un fait
religieux plutôt radicale on a laissé le
champ libre aux salafistes
de l'autre côté la gauche et l'extrême
gauche française au nom de la laïcité et
de la tolérance en accusant d'
islamophobie tous ceux qui
s'interrogeaient justement sur les
dérives et les mesures à prendre
empêcher de réfléchir sérieusement sur
le sujet il ya eu un espèce de déni de
réalité qui s'ajoutait au fait qu'on
comprenait pas ce qui se passe
l'attentât de charlie hebdo revendiqué
par al-qaïda il faut pas l'oublier
puis quelques jours après le lendemain
celui de montrouge et de l'hyper cacher
réalisé par coulibaly pour le compte de
neige a montré que nous n'étions pas
devant des cas isolés d'individus au
contraire on était devant des opérations
qui était planifié
mais il a fallu le bataclan le drame du
bataclan pour qu'il y ait enfin une
reconnaissance générale de la situation
dans notre pays
alors aujourd'hui se pose la question du
retour des dualiste et pour cela il faut
sortir du déni de réalité qui nourrit
les fantasmes de la société française il
faut regarder les choses en face parce
que face à ce défi il faut élargir le
débat
au delà de la question sécuritaire
face à ces militants qui font la
promotion du salafisme à l'intérieur de
zones dont plus d'une cinquantaine sont
devenus des zones de non droit il y a
une responsabilité réelle de la société
civile il faut admettre qu'une partie de
la population française vit en régime
d'exclusion sociale
pourquoi c'est parce que la tradition
française d'intégration que le fondement
même de la république telle qu'elle a
été conçue n'a pas marché il est donc
normal que ces populations se sentant
marginalisés se réfugie dans le
communautarisme cher à nos amis anglais
et j'ajouterai que si vous regardez les
statistiques produit par la dg et si par
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure en 2018
on voit que 28 % des musulmans en france
considèrent qu'ils sont en dehors de la
république donc ce qui est qu un
pourcentage très important alors comment
faire pour changer ça bien je crois
qu'on peut dire regardez ce qu'a fait le
hezbollah quand il a pris le contrôle du
liban sud en répandant aux attentes non
satisfaites de la population au plan de
l'éducation de la santé et du social
il faut différencier la vision des
djihadistes à travers la propagande de
dèche qui visaient à faire peur et
utiliser tous les moyens les plus
atroces et les plus médiatiques vous
souvenez de ces images épouvantables que
nous avons vu avec celle de la réalité
quotidienne de la plupart de ceux qui se
sont battus contre le régime syrien
il y avait une énorme différence entre
la propagande et la réalité et ceci me
rappelle en france pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent les historiens en
particulier la croisade des albigeois ou
plus près de nous avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale la guerre d'espagne où
les deux côtés ont fait nombre
d'atrocités du niveau par exemple de
radio sur glane c'est à dire des
horreurs mais ces horreurs sont loin de
la réalité vécue par beaucoup des
combattants volontaires qui avaient été
là bas si on va plus loin il est certain
que l'application rigoureuse de la
charia dans les territoires occupés par
des che était terrible à vivre pour la
population mais pour ces jihadistes
c'était le début de la concrétisation de
leurs rêves de califat islamique il en
accepter les contraintes et les excès
d'autant plus rappelons nous que l'islam
ça veut dire soumission à dieu dans le
cas de la oumma vers la communauté des
croyants
alors faut-il juger sur place les
jihadistes pour les empêcher de revenir
comment faire assurer la garde qui est
très coûteuse de dizaines de condamnés
si on ne veut pas qu'il puisse être
exécuté dans les pays où ils se trouvent
peut-on laisser entre les mains des
kurdes et courir le risque de les voir
passer entre celle des syriens qui
savent très bien comment les manipuler
et les instrumentaliser entre
parenthèses cela pourrait devenir un
énorme levier le chantage en tout genre
pour l'ensemble de l'europe et plus
particulièrement pour nous alors au delà
des fantasmes au delà des a priori et
des affirmations de tout genre il va
falloir trouver la moins mauvaise des
solutions
car soyons réalistes il n'y en a pas de
bonnes quand les terrorisant sortir de
prison un certain nombre sera toujours
motivé par la même idéologie mortifère
et difficile à contrôler cela est
surveillée ne suffit pas il faut traiter
l'ensemble du problème sous toutes ses
formes dans la durée en regardant ce qui
saute ur de nous pour apprendre des
autres en belgique en 2018
ils étaient 115 revenant et le processus
de déradicalisation dont on parle
beaucoup a été testé sans aucun résultat
convaincant et aujourd'hui nos amis
belges travaillent sur l'engagement
idéologique afin de diminuer le niveau
de dangerosité des détenus
l'objectif c'est de faire abandonner le
comportement violent plutôt que la
vision radicale de la société ce qui
passe par une réinsertion sociale avant
libération en allemagne il y avait un
programme qui s'appelait hayat et qui
aider ceux qui voulaient abandonner le
jihad
il a été arrêté parce qu avait pas de
clients l' approche privilégiée
aujourd'hui consiste à aider les
familles inquiètes de la radicalisation
de leurs proches mais également les
radicaliser qui ne sont jamais partis
et enfin les revenants du djihad ou ce
parti qui désirent rentrer parce qu'il y
en a qui sont loin mais qui voudrait
revenir mais 10 a pas commencé
cette action allemande prévoit un
soutien psychologique aux familles et un
travail de déconstruction des croyances
extrémistes avec de surcroît une aide
pour les démarches administratives
une réinsertion professionnelle et une
assistance psychologique un point
d'histoire
cette approche on sait qu'elles marchent
parce qu'elle a déjà été utilisé dans le
passé pour les déviances nazis dont au
royaume uni la situation est
complètement différente et on peut
regretter qu'en france ça soit pas la
même car en angleterre la communauté
musulmane s'implique totalement dans la
lutte contre le salafisme
alors il n'y a pas de numéro vert pour
alerter ou demander conseil
beya un programme qui s'appelle prévente
et qui est mis en oeuvre par les
différentes communautés musulmanes et
d'anciens djihadistes repenti en a
regroupés dans une fondation qui
s'appelle quillien notant qu'on
développe aussi la pratique des sports
de combat pour servir d'exutoire et de
compenser le goût de la violence de ceux
qui sont partis se battre en syrie
il est clair que l' approche sécuritaire
même en y ajoutant une dimension
psychologique est insuffisante la
déradicalisation menée en france par des
experts souvent auto déclarée n'a pas
donné les résultats attendus
mais comme ailleurs donc ce n'est pas
étonnant il est vrai qu'il est très
difficile de revenir en arrière si la
personne est passée à l'acte alors que
prévenir la radicalisation est possible
elle implique un enseignement moral et
civique et des actions sur le travail
l'emploi le logement et la réinsertion
à ce stade les imams peuvent jouer un
rôle important
il y a deux ans trente d'entre eux se
sont engagés à combattre la
radicalisation du jeunesse ignorante
mais également perturbé tentent elles
commettent des crimes au nom d'un islam
qu'ils ne connaissent pas en france
confronté à un conflit larvé entre
l'islam algérien et l'islam
mallet kit marocain qui est plus
pacifique on a laisser s'infiltrer des
imams salafistes venus du qatar et de
l'arabie saoudite qui bénéficiaient de
moyens financiers substantiels
soyons clairs ils ont prêché la guerre
sainte
comme l'église catholique l'a fait chez
nous à l'époque des croisades et le
problème c'est qu'on les a trop
longtemps laissé faire heureusement
après des années d'atermoiements le
gouvernement français a pris la mesure
du problème
il a promulgué 22 mesures en 2014 80 en
2016 60 en 2018 avec l'école et la
prison en tête des préoccupations
dans ce cadre il s'agit par exemple de
mieux détecter et évaluer et prendre en
charge les détenus radicaliser d'ouvrir
des centres de jour pour une prise en
charge individualisée de personnes
radicaliser
de mieux prendre en compte des revenants
mineurs d'éloigner des fonctionnaires
radicaliser comme ceux qu'on a connus à
la préfecture de police de mieux
contrôler et encadrer des écoles privées
hors contrat dont on sait que par lui et
sont hors contrat elles sont hors de
tout contrôle actuellement de mettre en
place à l'éducation nationale des
inspecteurs spécialisés
on peut ajouter le contrôle des réseaux
sociaux avec le retrait des contenus
illicites qui marche de mieux en mieux
il faut bien le dire
et puis on doit aussi parler et arrêter
les dérives dans les milieux sportifs
qui sont une plaie dans toutes les zones
où nous parlons
notons que l'état a décidé aussi de
réunir un comité scientifique pour mieux
comprendre la situation et soumettre des
idées
n'oublions pas également le site stuff
djihadisme qui est accessible à tout le
monde
pour compléter ce dispositif il faut
aussi détecter la radicalisation dans
l'entreprise et pouvoir prendre les
mesures appropriées et adaptées
alors là encore la loi savary permet le
criblage pour certaines professions
mais elle est insuffisante pour traiter
des personnels intérimaires et les
sous-traitants
parce qu'on ne l'avait pas prévu à
l'époque elle devrait également être
élargi à certains espaces géographiques
qui sont des zones sensibles comme le
suggère très justement le secrétaire
général d'aéroports de paris lé préfet
henri-michel comet
dans une audition qui l'a fait récemment
mais chez les parlementaires
par ailleurs on est bien obligé de
constater que les délais pour obtenir
les informations concernant des gens
qu'on soupçonne de dérives qui a dissout
ou d'être potentiellement jihadistes ont
encore beaucoup trop long par rapport
aux obligations de service et dans ce
cadre là il est certain que les liens
entre les entreprises et les services de
renseignement sont encore insuffisants
dans les entreprises étatiques quand je
pense à la ratp je pense à la sncf
ou à d'autres on forme les managers ont
les conseils pour apaiser les doutes
pour maintenir la relation sociale
on réaffirme les principes de laïcité et
de neutralité de non discrimination
vis-à-vis des femmes qui est un
véritable problème dans certaines
entreprises et toute transgression à la
règle et à l'éthique déclenché des
sanctions pouvant aller jusqu'au
licenciement
quand il s'agit de métiers sensible on
ne peut pas mettre des gens qui sont
potentiellement des terroristes sur des
pistes des aérodromes par exemple mais
le problème reste celui des contentieux
aux prud'hommes car la loi est imprécise
et ce qui fait que des gens qu'on sort
d'un côté peuvent revenir de l'autre ce
qui n'était évidemment pas admissible
ainsi la france s'est mise en ordre de
bataille et on ne peut que s'en réjouir
mais ne rêvons pas il faudra de la
constance pour garder le cap dans la
durée parce qu'il faudra du temps
d'autant que certains groupes de
pression et leurs leaders d'opinion
continueront à semer le doute dans
l'esprit des français au nom du déni de
réalité et d'intérêt malheureusement
souvent extra territoriaux à bientôt
[Musique]